good morning Millennials happy Friday
welcome back to the morning toast it is
a gloomy but wonderful Friday here in
New York and we are just wrapping up
another week in the queue hey Claude
hey guys girls girlie girls what's up
Claudia here still talking like RuPaul
because I finished season seven last
night and you know what Jax we're just
fishy as [ __ ] and that's not our fault
it's not our fault I don't know what it
means but um proud fish yeah I don't
really like understand fishy I think
it's like when you really um like do
your makeup so well in your glam so well
that you are like the most high fashion
woman like you work at Vogue and that's
us oh my god that's actually me today
because for the first time and I think a
month I have done a full fetch of makeup
if you're a podcast listener I have a
full face of makeup on for a multitude
of reasons I have some content to shoot
today
my husband's 30th birthday is tomorrow
and I know he doesn't watch the show so
I can stay here that I have like a
little something planned tonight so it's
just a day where I need a thought and I
I'm really feeling the effects of
wearing makeup like I really feel like
myself the person who said like a few
weeks ago I should try getting glammed
up and maybe I'll feel better was right
well I'm so happy for you I'm actually
reverting into the man I started as like
I'm literally starting to look uglier
and uglier my hair is getting like
cracked and like I thought that not
using heat would make it like healthy
and no it's broken and sad just like me
yeah I went like now I'm using heat
twice a week just to give my hair like a
little bit of shape and then I don't
like touch it up every single day but
today I did a full hair as well but
that's gonna need looks really good
amazing thank you I mean honestly was a
fun activity and if you're looking for
something to do and also I was really
inspired by one of my inspirations Kylie
Jenner because she's been getting full
glam like having a little party in her
house with her tequila but a brand that
she won't share with the class yet and
her Hawaiian rolls and I was just like
she looks like she's having a grand old
time and if she's like why not me
totally Hawaiian rolls are so epic when
when quarantine first started and like I
wasn't sure if it was like a joke and
everyone was like running to the grocery
store like these people are nuts then I
was like damn maybe this is not like not
a big deal so I sent Ben to the grocery
store and we were the last people to get
everything there was nothing left Ben
bought ten packs of Hawaiian rolls we
never ate them I found them in my
cabinet the other day covered in mold oh
my god I found a lot of stuff covered in
mold mold is some really crazy thing I
know my garlic cupboard and mold what
the [ __ ]
yeah I had a avocados some old avocados
cover name mold and then also vegetables
do this thing in the fridge where like
if they don't get moldy but they just
start to leak out like this like they
juice on the inside just like leaks out
and ruins your fridge so I've had a
couple bad zucchinis that way um it's a
crazy time for mold and I know I'm we've
been talking about it and like we always
say you know the quarantine is a roller
coaster and I'm feeling I'm like an
emotional high like I'm not feeling
terrible this week I was feeling pretty
terrible last week but this week I'm
just done cooking like I'm done with the
kitchen I'm done loading the dishwasher
four [ __ ] times a day wiping down the
stove 10 times a day like I'm done I'm
eating a bowl of cereal for every meal
because I'm [ __ ] done and I'm eating
honey nut cheerios I'm getting my
cholesterol down and I'm done yeah I
went to the store yesterday and I found
some really good plant-based meat
options in frozen food section I was
telling then I had these like chicken
poppers but it's fake chicken last night
and then I also you know Boca burger the
company they make meatless crumbles as
well so I got two packs of those so I
can make tacos
I could make meatless Bolognese I'm
really excited also because it's Acts
birthday tomorrow I feel like that's
kind of like you know making something
happen for me like it feels like there's
an occasion we have like a lot of
birthday's coming up so it feels kind of
like normal life um
but his favorite food ever is pesto
pasta so I am cooking pesto pasta
tonight for dinner and really know that
there's a livers yeah but honestly it's
so much better when when I make when you
make it at home if it turns out right
and you know what I don't think that
Serafina has a pesto pasta that he likes
because every time I order Serafina he
like doesn't
what to get that is such a like weird
thing to like I didn't even know Zach
like lived for pesto lives for it so and
also when I went to the store I got a
chip Brioni brand pesto apparently like
the things that you learn when you go to
the store um Tribbiani like sells their
pesto so it should be a chip Brioni
level hmm
will be having cereal and chips for
dinner at my house shabbat shalom
shabbat shalom chips are really like
everything these days you know what I
don't have any chips in my house like I
started out quarantine with a bunch of
chips ate them all and never restocked
except Tostitos which are such a
versatile chip I just can't praise them
enough but I need some big leis and make
ruffles Cheetos like I need some chips
I've been loving and we've been going on
a chip round like two times a week I've
been loving kettle chips specifically
salt and vinegar mmm
but then after you eat the salt and
vinegar you can't really go back to the
regular because then the regulars have
no flavor and mesquite barbecue we used
to eat them in college all the time I
just love the Mesquite life
the problem with salt and vinegar is
obviously that you can't go back to
eating regular chips because it just
tastes bland and then you're literally a
monster with your breath so it's
literally I love vinegar also I did the
towel trick of washing my towels with
vinegar and then baking soda and the gym
clothes smell is gone you guys it
completely works people were also
telling me to try this method of like
stripping or your clothes by putting
them in the bathtub you saw these posts
oh yes um but like this solves my
problem like maybe if I get to next
level of mildewy towels I'll do that but
if you guys are having a smelly towel
issue one wash them with vinegar a cup
of vinegar and then after that wash use
a half a cup of baking soda and also
stop watching your towels with fabric
softener that works out there I did a
similar trick on my dishwasher it was
smelly as [ __ ] in there and I did
vinegar and baking soda now it doesn't
smell good but it does not smell bad do
you like I love the smell of vinegar
when I was like pouring all the cups and
I was like so excited are you sick
I love it I was pouring it literally
like trying not to throw up like gagging
so hard
SiC vinegar I'm so good in salt and
vinegar chips are so good you should
take apple cider vinegar shots they're
really good for you if you can stomach
maybe I will
I actually think I have some apple cider
vinegar for some recipe I didn't make
sickening well it's like bleach I you're
so wrong this I know everyone's
wondering like Claudia are you drinking
coffee in your mugs tea no I'm drinking
lemonade oh yeah I'm from where Crystal
Light Crystal Light is my absolute
quarantine best friend because I have
such a hard time drinking water but
laying around all day and not drinking
water gives me terrible headaches like
I've had headaches almost every day in
quarantine because I don't drink water
so now I'm doing crystallite which is
water it counts that's good also liquid
IV is the perfect thing for that too I
need to get better of having like a
water bottle in bed with me because all
I've been drinking is iced tea but it's
not it's not good enough I drink a lot
of water when I work out yesterday
actually it's such a productive day
even though the day started when I
thought I wasn't even gonna do the toast
like I wasn't feeling well um but I
started to feel better we moved cam
toast and let everyone know and now
everyone's so excited I was so excited
for cam toast yesterday like I really
can't wait um and then I did a workout a
virtual training session with the live
method which was so great did a little
peloton went and got my migraine meds
went to the store it was a good day I
literally didn't get off my loveSac on
my computer but I was like very
productive but like not physically like
I did so much work yesterday that counts
that's great that's great my motto of
quarantine is that counts
my motto of quarantine is we got through
the day it doesn't matter how serious
and I watched all the TV I needed to
watch which we're gonna recap Keeping Up
with the Kardashians and Real Housewives
of New York both of which I very strong
feelings about um me too
more so Keeping Up with the Kardashians
which is just like it's my happy place
Oh Khloe Kardashian tweeted back at me
last night when I was keeping this ah
she that was good I have started to
watch Kardashians live because I every
time I tweet about it they tweet me back
Kim retweeted me last time and then the
week after that I watched it like late
on my DVR but unless you're they
usually tweet with East Coast time so
now I'm like motivated to watch live
just so I could be thirsty on Twitter I
mean that's a great motivation also
because like watching as soon as it
comes out is the best way to watch it's
literally I will talk about it but like
these are my people like I'm so obsessed
I'm so obsessed with Kim kardashian-west
like I can't even tell you she is just
like my spiritual leader you know what
it's like I was really actually thinking
about yesterday like who I relate to the
most and to me like Kim is the end all
be all icky is just everything of the
sort but like last night's episode it
was really just like damn Chloe is a
[ __ ] rider too I like pretending with
these stupid storylines like she is
constantly time and time again putting
the show on her back oh for sure I had
like so much respect for her but there's
just like I don't know maybe it's like a
personality thing I just like I live for
Kim and it's so nice to have a celebrity
in your life who you feel like you agree
with them on every sink like anything
that they do you ride and you die for
them yeah like whenever I think of like
oh I'm the Kylie you know like when
people always try and like connect us as
much as I would like absolutely love to
be the Kim because I feel like I'm just
like a star whenever I watch the show I
totally like see you see Kim and you
like you both are really like this um
calm force in the family where it's like
people really look to you and they look
to Kim for like spiritual guidance like
I don't make a decision without running
it by you and people everyone does that
to Kim like even with the embryos Chloe
was like what do I do like everyone kind
of even though Kim's not the oldest
she's just like so wise and I feel like
you guys are similar in that way oh my
God thank you that is so kind yeah
everyone always tries to like line us up
and it doesn't totally aligned um but I
do feel like like I in the role of the
family I feel like I relate most to Kim
and then I feel like you who would you I
want to say Chloe just because like
you're the most fun and funny but it
doesn't totally match up no it's just
it's not it's not they're putting out
there no anyways just a fun thing to do
yeah I think it's time that we can like
that into Kardashians et's time for the
past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jackie but if I may a
word from our sponsors thrive market and
online membership base market on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable with guaranteed savings you
can enjoy Members Only prices up to 25
to 50% off traditional retail prices
they are 100% committed to the never
engaging in surge pricing they promise
that thrive market you will find the
same Members Only savings no matter what
you can buy the highest quality healthy
and sustainable products from thrive
market by thousands of wholesome food
home and beauty products curated just
for your member their members find
everything you need from organic and
non-gmo food clean beauty safe
supplements and non-toxic home plus
ethical means sustainable food clean
wine and more it's healthy without the
hassle because it's all shipped right to
you skip the store and the lines and you
could shop by more than seventy diets
like keto paleo gluten free vegan
non-gmo Fairtrade certified bpa free and
more and they are making a commitment
during this koban 19 time they're
working 24/7 to ensure that their
members are getting the essentials they
need as quickly as possible while
maintaining their commitment to carbon
neutrality so no air shipments at ten
times the carbon impact and their fair
practices to their website warehouse
team so I feel like now is such a great
time to become a thrive market member
because it's that guilt free membership
you're getting that sustainable product
at a fair price and they're getting it
out as fast as they can so go to thrive
market calm slash toast to join thrive
market you can choose the membership
model that best fits your lifestyle
lifestyle they have one month one year
options Jackie and I both have the one
year options because we love it but you
can try it for a month the one year
option it's great because it breaks down
to just five dollars a month so you end
up saving money um but the best part
about being a free market member is that
you join and they give through thrive
gives their one four one membership
matching program every paid membership
sponsor is a free one for a low income
family so you can feel good knowing that
you're getting your food getting your
eat eating away and then also doing good
for your community if you sign up today
you can get $20 and shopping credit on
your first order go to thrive market.com
slash toast to try it out
that's thrive market comm slash toast
check it out we love thrive market here
at the toast I feel like in this climate
everyone really needs a thrive market
subscription I love thrive market I love
their products have discovered so many
brands and products that are now like
I go twos they make it so easy to like
check out their prices are so amazing
get on the thrive market train getting
your groceries online in 2020 is the way
to go totally ok first story wrapping up
the big news of the week Gigi Hadid has
confirmed her pregnancy on The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon Gigi Hadid
officially confirmed she's going to be a
mom days after the news broke that she
was expecting a child with boyfriend
Zayn Malik Hadid opened up in an
interview with Jimmy Fallon quote
obviously we wish we could have
announced on our own terms she said but
we're very excited and happy and
grateful for everyone's well wishes and
support especially during this time it's
a nice silver lining to be able to be
home and together and really experience
it the pregnancy day-by-day it was a
cute in Rio Jimmy's like so happy I
think they're actually like really
friends like like they're very few
celebrities who live in New York and I
feel like the ones that do like they
stick together and Jimmy Fallon was
being really cute you know he's his
usual drunk self but he was still being
very sweet and endearing um I just you
know I don't really hear Gigi Hadid talk
that much and every time I do I'm like
reminded by how low her voice isn't just
so unique not only good or a bad way
it's just like so unique inand I don't
know a lot of people with that type of
voice and I'm always just like oh yeah
that's what she sounds like yeah I think
a lot of people have that reaction
because we don't really hear from her uh
literally that often but she's obviously
so excited she looks so happy and
glowing and even in on the zoom FaceTime
situation like she's just radiating and
I'm happy that she like just told us
straight up you know I'm out with it
I wonder if obviously someone spoiled
their news and links it to TMZ I wonder
what their um announcement would have
been you know like how they would have
done it they would a they have done like
a photo shoot a cover of Vogue like I
don't see her just doing something on
Instagram like a post like a nude belly
post no they're so high fashion I feel
like maybe she would have like shown up
to the Met Gala with a bump that would
have been like kind of iconic definitely
something on the cover of Vogue would be
so sick they've been in a vogue photo
shoot together before that was actually
really sickening so um I do feel sad
that both day and we got robbed of that
moment but I'm glad she's just embracing
it not like pretending it's
happening um I'm just excited for like
the looks I feel like she's such a like
so many fabulous people get pregnant but
like very rarely just like the top model
in the world at the height of her career
like everyone is gonna want to dress her
for every pregnant outing if we ever get
out and it's kind of gonna be like
sickening it would be sickening but we
there's four months left of her
pregnancy and there's like a lot of
social distancing left even though May
15th we're getting out you guys we're
not gonna be more gala
yeah the Met Gala is not gonna happen so
I'm just excited for these two also
their quarantine on the farm tremon in
Pennsylvania like is a dream a dream
like I that's just should be us that
should be us damn that should be me
holding your hand oh this isn't a story
today because um I haven't even gone
through it all but like the new music
that's out today is just everything of
the sort first of all um six feet apart
Luke Holmes the song is here he recorded
it he literally just answered our
prayers like thank you Luke Holmes the
song is so good it's the anthem of
quarantine up until now my quarantine
anthem had been 2016 by Sam honks it's
all about like lost time and what you
would do if you got that time back but
now at 62 Parker's we're now we're
looking forward to the times we'll have
when we're no longer six feet apart my
quarantine song has been a song that I
found on tick tock by that but I knew
about the artist she's like that new
up-and-coming um country artist - Neal
something see Neal towns if I ever get
to heaven got a long list of questions
like do you make a snowflake
it's a beautiful song that's my easy I
need to add it to the quarantines
playlist yes I looked for it I just
assumed it was on yesterday when I went
to go play it in the bathtub but it
wasn't and it's just such a sweet song
about all the things she would ask God
if she ever gets to heaven that's so
beautiful wait I'm adding it right now
what's it called um holding up holding
out for the one somebody's daughter
where you are the most beautiful things
no I remember not really recognizing the
name of the song oh I had just checked
my phone one second it's really well so
I just want to say the corn scenes
playlist has 5,700 followers because
everyone is just loving the vibe like
it's it's so the vibe it's my Spotify
playlist on Spotify my name on Spotify
is Jackie O Weinreb and the playlist is
called Hornstein and if you're like
looking to catch a vibe at any point
between now and the end of the pandemic
listen to this playlist it'll get you
through it's getting me through what's
named in the song I can't find her
okay we'll deal with this later also
another song that I wanted to mention
the savage remix with Beyonce I was
called on the wall sorry okay I was
listening to the remix as I got ready
this morning and it was just putting a
pep in my step
it's everything of the sort all the
references she literally like chopstick
talk and it's all like only so exciting
only fans it's just so exciting for
everyone who has been enjoying savage up
until this point like the remix is
everything we needed it got me thinking
like do we need an only tems
I actually because I'm in the morning
tube which is like the YouTube based
Facebook group for the toasters it's
very confusing and I've started to just
like know so much about youtubers
because like I've started to fall in
love but Jeffery and it's like then once
you know one you start to know more like
I was following this Miranda sings drama
last night it was [ __ ] crazy um but
I've kind of been enamored I'll say the
word is with Trisha Paytas and she is
like a crazy only fans where like I
think she makes like literally so much
money a month and someone in the
toasters was like did anyone sees
Trish's only fans and I went on it and
hers is like straight-up porn she was
literally putting like a dildo in her
ass
it was crazy so while I don't think
that's like my path um I totally like
respect and support you if that's the
path that you want to go down I will say
however I think that our version of only
fans is patreon it is so patreon.com
slash a morning toast if you're if you
are wanting to see us like you've never
seen us before not nude but you know
open close we're emotionally nude
yeah we're spreading them emotionally
big time opening up emotionally okay
ready okay this episode is all about
qarn bebés because um next up Ashley
Simpson is pregnant she's expecting her
second child with her husband Evan Ross
so Diana Ross's daughter-in-law is
pregnant and it's just so exciting for
the future and sneetches of to Jessica
Simpson the couple announced and enjoy
I'm so happy for Tracy you know this is
great for her Tracy Ellis this is her
sister yeah that's important honestly
like this family now that I read Jessica
Simpson's book I have like a deeper
appreciation for the Simpsons and for
Ashlee Simpson too um and like the
fusion of the raw Simpsons is so epic
yeah it's strange I'm not gonna lie to
be honest it's very very rare that you
say a story and I hadn't heard it I had
no idea she was pregnant and it's just
so weird I feel like Ashlee Simpson and
Evan Ross are the culmination of just
like irrelevance but but they're also
like so close to like Diana Ross Jessica
Simpson these stars but they themselves
are completely irrelevant remember when
we were at the airport standing in line
at Hudson News and they were right
behind us yeah yeah I agree with you
that they're irrelevant but it's like
it's because she was living in the
shadows of someone else's dream and I
feel like Evan Ross might have heard
that song and related to it you know and
I feel like that might have been what
connected them just like this for sure
but I know that she was standing in the
shadow of someone else's dream but like
for a while she was everything of the
sort like she didn't really get pushed
to the side completely no no she didn't
so I think I think they have a nice
little life together
Oh for sure and they enjoy all the
fruits of like being related to famous
people but I just find it so interesting
that you could be so close to fame from
all angles like an icon Diana Ross but
still be so irrelevant no I think it's
the opposite like I feel like they get
like all of this like you know she farts
it's a news story she has a route they
get a real show it with a reality show
on E they get like a shot at everything
just because there's someone's bloodline
yes
guess you could see it that way but like
I just don't consider like their one
season on e and their us weekly
write-ups to be like a level of Fame
no that's that in the CNH like that is
like textbook see list see list yes
that's what I'm saying like yes for sure
but like the people that they associate
themselves with Jessica Simpson and
Diana Ross like that is permanent AAA
list yeah they're a by association no I
disagree no they're not a list I would
agree with that but they are cute and
they seem like really happy celebrity
family and that's that's a big deal in
this day and age oh and you know what
I'm sorry I take it back actually I met
Evan Ross at a party once he was so nice
like literally all these people were
being like so weird and he was being so
nice to me maybe was because we were
both losers like we both just kind of
like fit in maybe he was really nice
actually I take it back he's nice I
really I like them and she was so
supportive of Jessica through her cold
journey through life in the [ __ ] and
um yeah she's a really good sister like
they are skinny vibes and so I support
any sister who supports the sister hmm
interesting I didn't know that they they
had Steve I beside that just change
things it changes things and you should
just finish the damn book I know you
know I started like the first three
pages ever picked it back up because I
put it somewhere I can't find it and I
have two copies how crazy is that I
cannot fight either copies because I
bought one for a trip left it at home
and then in the airport on the trip I
found the book so I bought it for the
trip never at it brought it home read
three pages now I can't find either of
them it's so good you're missing out
you're missing out no okay
next story a little more bad bad news
because Anderson Cooper's welcome to a
baby boy be a surrogate I'm loving this
trend of people just like dropping their
babies like Beyonce just dropping her
lemonade album like no warning boom baby
baby yeah I'm so here for it as well
Anderson Cooper is a dad surprise on
Thursday the longtime news anchor
revealed the happy news on CNN and also
on Instagram where he shared a slideshow
of photos of his son Wyatt Morgan Cooper
Cooper welcomed Wyatt who was named
after the journalist father on Monday
the ax surrogate he said Wyatt waits
seven pounds
two ounces at birth quote he is sweet
and soft and healthy and I am beyond
happy that is so cute and I just like
can only think about him and Andy's
bebut just being best friends like the
new AC in town no it was so cute I
watched the little clip like literally
the most CNN I've ever watched in my
life and it was really really like he's
really just like it was very cute he's
getting like a little choked up and I
had the same thought it's like I love
how him and Andy have like the same PR
person for their baby like boom dropping
a baby and they both have babies via
surrogate and they both like have so
much respect for the surrogate industry
like the way that Andy was I mean
Anderson on his show was like so so
grateful for this sory it was really
sweet and you know Andy's like always go
to Albany fighting the legislature all
that stuff so I'm very excited for the
friendship between Benjamin Cohen and
Wyatt Morgan Cooper because they're
gonna be so cool yeah they're gonna be
really cool very fun meet a lot of
pressure you know to be like that cool
no or to like get a lot you know our
dads are best friends they work together
we're on tour we're staying in the hotel
yeah they're not even like this kid
totally like remember um I just remember
growing up like everyone has those
family friends and now as an adult I
realize it's because like I want to hang
out with you Jackie so our kids have to
be friends whether they like it or not
it's not about that yeah just yeah
that's what family friends are it's like
because your parents are friends and
they just want to hang out so the two of
you better hang out me see each other in
the hallways say hi and it's like weird
cuz like you hung out this weekend but
like you're not really friends no and
you're not in different grades and like
the kids are like how do you guys know
each other and it's like our family
turns together I don't know exactly what
it is but it's just so funny how like
your perception of family friends
changes when you're a kid versus like an
adult like I totally get it now like all
my friends like when we have kids like
our kids better be friends cuz I wanna
hang out with my friends yeah but they
won't be real true friends they'll just
be family friends but every now and then
very rarely do family friends transition
into either true friendship or true love
yeah I think mostly it can be true
friendship when the kids are the exact
same age because if they're in different
grades they're never gonna be tight yeah
you know so they're sure my my two cents
on family friends and also like there is
a limit to how many family friends you
should have I just want to say that like
I think family friends are cool I
understand it I respect it um but like
you can't be family friends with the
whole town okay you can't but there are
certainly people who try like yeah I
mean I'm you're probably thinking
someone I'm thinking someone like just
that family that was like friends with
everyone it's like chill but what do you
try improve what do you try and proven
like your bar mitts is gonna be out of
control there's too many people too many
people yeah agreed okay next up Kylie
Jenner posts a loving post to Travis
Scott for his birthday saying quote love
you forever Kylie Jenner has very
appropriately the story is brought to
you by OkCupid I'm sorry Wow love you
forever if you haven't heard about
OkCupid yet we're here to tell you about
you should give it a shot in 2020 are
you looking for the Travis to your Kylie
that means to your Jackie debenture
Claudia check out OkCupid a lot of
people don't know that okay Cuban has
really changed the game they asked you
the most thoughtful questions so that
they can learn more about you the type
of person you are and the type of person
you're looking for the more questions
you answer the better they are at
finding matches with someone you have in
common with so the questions are a
little different than the standard like
what are you looking for what are your
interests they ask you are you a cat or
a dog person do you listen to any
podcast because if someone listens to
the test they're automatically boyfriend
material how do you feel about kids just
things that you wouldn't normally think
of when it comes to dating profiles but
actually really get to know you a lot
better OkCupid actually works it is the
most mentioned dating app in the New
York Times wedding section it is the
only app in the world where you can
match on a range of issues that you care
about from whether or not your dog or
cow person to how you feel about climate
change stop the mindless time on dating
apps and go to the app where you choose
what matters OkCupid is totally free so
we don't have an offer or link just
download OkCupid today go on a great
date this week and then tell us about
the great person that you met we will
come to the wedding and I will do you
one better
I'll come to your wedding I'm
officiating that [ __ ] and also sing a
small but powerful song love it sign on
find love just like this love in our
next story which is really cute so it's
Travis Scott's birthday yesterday
Kylie posted a series of photos of him
and stormy saying dad happy birthday to
Daddy of the
I'm slowly but surely starting to accept
the fact that storm is a daddy's girl
but whatever we went half on greatness
the most beautiful smart loving and
funny little baby the best gift
okay I'm crying love you forever I'm
unclear on their status let's do you
have an update uh I don't have like any
legitimate update I I don't think that
they're together romantically um maybe
they'll [ __ ] around and have another
baby
as she said but um I think right now
they're not like together but they were
quarantined together I think or was that
Tristan and Chloe I don't know I don't
know I don't know if they're together I
was also leaning towards them not being
together but I like that they keep the
relationship civil obviously for me and
because of course she probably still
loves him the father of her child I just
love seeing photos that I was never
gonna see if it weren't for Travis's
birthday like him riding on a bike
around Calabasas his store me in the
back like that's this kind of [ __ ] I
[ __ ] live for no say man I love that
they call themselves Stormies mom and
dad because that's what we call them
like she posted a photo of them like
saying Stormies mommy and daddy and he
always calls her like Hermes mom he's
like I love Stormy's mom and I always
will he said in an interview so they're
just like copacetic and chill yeah I
mean I'm sure it's like more um there's
more to it than what we're seeing but
what I'm seeing is like co-parenting at
its finest and like maybe a little
glimmer of hope that these two like
might one day just like fall back in
love fall back maybe it seems like
they're just on such good terms like if
Kylie wanted another baby and she wants
it to be Stormy's full relative like get
in the sack jump in yeah yeah I think
that they would be open to that I feel
like that's where Tristan and Chloe are
headed towards and I really like that we
I need to just got to Kardashian's recap
because like the promo is sickening
I feel like that's such a mature way of
like parenting it's like having a baby
with someone who you're not with but
like you already had a baby with it's
like that's so mature
yeah very Kourtney and Scott yeah but
didn't they have the three kids while
they were together
yeah they wrote it out till the end but
like it wasn't easy it wasn't easy
okay our fifth and final story are you
ready for it hmm it's an interesting
question yeah I'm ready are you
struggling to use space ID with your
mask
Apple will soon solve that problem with
masks becoming a commonplace tool to
stop the spread of novel coronavirus
some iPhone owners are finding their
once useful face ID function mostly
useless Apple is changing that in the
latest beta release of iOS thirteen
point five multiple developers set a new
face ID features mat feature makes it
easier to unlock the iPhone without
having to take your mask off in the new
version of iOS states ID will recognize
when someone is wearing a mask and the
film will instantly pull up the passcode
entry screen no more constant searching
for your face the fotch ID tool still
won't unlock your iPhone unless you take
your mask off but it will make the
switch to the passcode unlock option
significantly faster [ __ ] that that's
not what I thought this was gonna be
that's not a real solution even though
this isn't a problem I've actually had
whenever I'm wearing a mask I'm usually
not touching my phone or trying not to
so this isn't a problem that I find to
be like a true you know worldwide
phenomenon also I don't think that this
is a solution it's just like get to plan
B faster it's not that hard to go from
face ID to passcode no and also I
thought the solution was gonna be okay
we're gonna do new profiles where we get
really close on your eyes and like we'll
be able to open your phone like from my
ID from dying that's alright that sounds
like a solution this doesn't seem like a
solution no but it is interesting how
like now this is like a glimmer into how
the world might be different after all
of this yeah for sure
I think you're not gonna be the subway
yes yeah I heard that they're closing
down York City subways from like 1:00 to
5:00 in the morning to finally clean it
for the first time in a literally 200
years I can't believe that we are now
two months into quarantine and now
they're thinking about cleaning the
subway didn't it occur to anyone
everyone's talking about Wu Han the bat
the lab no coronavirus my friends
started in the subway I fight me on that
ya know it's very exciting um that there
will be a clean subway I'm actually
gonna go I need to see what it looks
like yeah I'm sure it'll be nice I hope
that they take it seriously like not
just the cars but the tunnels like this
is a major major um
and I just don't trust the man in charge
of New York City to fulfill it in a way
that's effective but we'll see at least
you did it like come on I'm so like at
least it's happening
um well Governor Cuomo's in charge of
the MTA so that it's like a Cuomo de
Blasio initiative but it's both of them
hmm okay well that's better look I'm
sorry but both of them have done [ __ ]
up that it took this long to clean the
subway that's what I'm saying so it's
like the person in charge of now
cleaning the subways the person who also
stopped it from ever being cleaned so
right so no congratulations are in order
here no and I'm not feeling like that
zest I had five minutes ago you know I'm
not feeling excited because whoever is
in charge has obviously been making very
poor judgment calls when it comes to the
MTA the fare hikes this disgust it's
just those dumb machines they installed
in the subway like robots for your
ticket no no okay let's get into our TV
recaps because that's really why we're
here today
it is the TV recap segment brought to
you by noon getting in shape doesn't
have to be about losing a specific
amount of weight or a magic number on
the scale it's about building healthier
habits feeling better about yourself
it's fitting into that favor if fitting
into that favorite pair of jeans and
feeling better about yourself is what
you care about great but there are many
reasons you might want to practice
self-care and every person is different
new is the habits changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology they teach you why you do the
things that you do and it empowers you
with the tools that you need to break
bad habits and replace them with better
ones numa's a diet is not a diet it is a
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
no food is considered good bad or
off-limits it just teaches you
moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want so that is not
required they have one of the biggest
and most accurate food databases
available and lets you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance so Ben has been
working with the nutritionist because
he's really just kind of spiraled out
during quarantine and the nutritionist
recommended new because Ben is now
tracking all of his calories and we
don't have a scale like a food scale so
like when you're making chicken like you
need to know but what it is and like
it's just very amusing so since we don't
have a scale in new miu can visualize
poor
some sizes and numa's literally made for
Ben he's obsessed that he was like
reading me his diary about all the
things that he ate yesterday and it's
actually really working for him because
it's so unfair like he lost seven pounds
in a week because he's a man it's just
so unfair but it's really working for
him and it can work for you guys to chat
with your girl specialist and the name
community to get and give help to people
going through the same thing you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps make a big progress sign up for
your trial today at noon dot-com slash
toasts that's n oom comm slash toast
what do you have to lose visit new
massage shows to start your trial today
that's n oom calm / toast my noon goals
have really changed since being in the
queue like I feel like my goals used to
be very straightforward like lose weight
feel great etc but now might all of my
priorities have shifted and like my
eating habits have changed and I'm just
kind of thrown out of whack in terms of
like what to eat how to eat like when to
eat and I've been leaning on new more
than ever to help me like stay in check
and just make sure I'm eating enough
protein and like getting enough of the
nutrients and not eating too much
garbage and that way I like feel better
about myself and those have been my
goals and it's been invaluable during
the Q and if you are looking for that
sort of like personalised helpful
training system I couldn't recommend it
more are we wanting to do New York or
Kardashian first Kardashian because I
watched it first ok such a fabulous
episode I love it they're on at 8
o'clock I can't stress enough how much
this Thursday 8 o'clock is so fabulous
mm-hmm I totally agree I was like ready
for it so we kind of got two episodes
like the first episode was like a little
silly like Chloe being Kim's Chris's
assistant Scott leaning more into his
family background and then the Christmas
stuff which was so fascinating to me
because I saw it through two lenses like
I remember sitting on the show and being
like why they do it at Kourtney's it was
kind of lackluster and now just knowing
like the all the drama it makes total
sense yeah like when we saw it then on
Instagram and stuff like they didn't do
a good job of like well why would they
they're at a party they're not gonna
explain what the vision was for the
party but like now seeing it all I
thought it was lovely like a bee you
know he wanted it to be very much her
aesthetic and it was and when we saw in
an interim and we were just used to like
Kim's party last year
she had a [ __ ] snow hill and sledding
and like tree it was just so crazy um
but I thought it was really beautiful it
looks like everyone had so much fun they
didn't let the crew in and I feel like
they're just trying to make more of like
these opportunities where they can just
be themselves um same with Christmas
morning and I just was obsessed with the
logistics of like where they're gonna
have everything and like what it would
look like it everyone's different house
like the fact that Kylie would have a
chef and everything would be like so
staffed whereas Kourtney doesn't want
any of that yet she doesn't cook so what
are they gonna eat yeah I was feeling
really conflicted because part of me
agreed with Kourtney it's like nobody
wants to have the party at her house so
Kourtney's thing is like I'll have the
party at my house if we can keep
Christmas morning at my house I actually
thought that was like a fair trade um
and I thought Kylie was being like a
little stubborn just like I'm doing at
my house like I don't care what anyone
says
like not even appreciating the fact that
Kourtney was giving up her house for the
party so that there would be a party
because there wouldn't be one if it
weren't for Kourtney and so not usually
when to take Kourtney side um but I also
understand how all the girls were like I
just want to wake up I want my kids to
wake up in their own house and like have
Christmas morning so like that's where
it's like where you grow up it's like
you want the things that you had as a
kid but you wanted with all your cousins
but it can't be at everyone's house yeah
it's like they had all these traditions
growing up but like their aunts and
uncles and cousins weren't making these
sacrifices too so like things do change
when people have their own families and
like stormy wants to believe that Santa
comes to her house and I think that
that's really fair so I think the
solution they came up with was perfect
everyone opens presents at their own
house santa came to their house and then
they have like this big brunch um it
really like shocks me I was thinking
about it a lot last night because I was
also watching Kim's stories like they
wake up so early
Kim wakes up Kim has her trainer come
every morning at 5:45
that's insane like I feel like I will
never be successful or like as
successful as I want to be because I
love to sleep and I love to sleep in and
I can't even wake up at 9:00 a.m. on a
weekday let alone a weekend like they're
talking about going to each other's
houses at 8:00 a.m. after having a full
morning like I don't know when do I get
once you get to that point in life where
you just like maybe it's when you have
kids and they wake you up and you're
just sleep schedules turn off but like
the amount that I sleep like I'm now
self-conscious of it like I feel like I
just can't be a success because I sleep
well you definitely sleep a lot less
once you have kids like they just say
you never sleep the same way again so I
think that'll change and also with the
Christmas stuff it seemed like a lot but
when it's my understanding that when you
have kids on Christmas like they [ __ ]
wake up at the crack of dawn because
they're so [ __ ] excited and they wake
you up so I don't think like they're all
just waking up at 6:00 because they feel
like it's like the kids have been up for
hours and they want their presents yeah
but like I think in general they just
wake up so early and I wish I could be
that way but it can't I even tried to
wake up an hour earlier today to work
out before today's toast and I was like
why I was like my alarm went off I was
like why would I do that I'm going back
to sleep totally except you know I'm on
my news sleep schedule and it's actually
really beneficial so I won't go into
that again because I know nobody cares
but um it was a great episode um I do
agree that they didn't not that it was
their job to like capture the essence of
the party on social media but it was
much more um stylized on camera like
when I saw it like I actually got a
vision it's not what I would have chosen
in particular we just saw them like keep
showing Courtney's interest with these
ugly red flowers that they sell at
Trader Joe's like that's what I thought
like the big moment was but it was
actually really more for the kids they
have like the Christmas village I
thought it was nice yeah I thought it
was really nice um and so I'm glad were
able to see everything in hindsight and
like it was it was nice it was nice yeah
it was just a good episode like not
nothing too crazy Scott makes me so sad
like um losing both his parents and
within a month of each other and just
like not even like speaking about them
ever and he like packed it I remember
that episode write him in corny just
like literally packed up the house in
the day and like didn't even like keep
certain stuff's he's like he only had
that one box thank God his uncle knew
that it was in Audrey's house and they
brought it from New York but um it would
just made me sad yeah is really sad but
he's so cute I love the bar mitzva
footage I love that we're getting
Scott's home videos now because like
they were just loving playing home
videos and it's like if you ever had a
Bar Mitzvah like on Long Island like you
know it's like when they come around
with a microphone and if you like say
something about the bar mitzvah boy like
I feel like for anyone who's been in
that situation like watching that video
was like oh I have that exact same video
but like other people wouldn't
understand it
oh so he was the most beautiful child
I've ever seen Leonardo DiCaprio crazy
Mazel Tov Jackie you did beautiful this
morning and you look beautiful gorgeous
we're so proud of you we love you let's
have the best time tonight yes and all
the legs thick Long Island accents like
that's how our son into you tented
you're out Taurus so beautifully today
I'm so proud of you up up and away
yeah please come up and like candle
number three
yeah no one's was worse than ours now I
want to transition from talking about
such a great episode of Kardashians into
literally talking about like one of the
most disappointing episodes of Real
Housewives of New York one that actually
like put me in a depression Oh
interesting why I just couldn't believe
that like these are the Real Housewives
of New York do you know what I mean it's
like especially coming from Beverly
Hills like where Kyle's fashion show
like we like dragged on it even though
like it was really well put together and
like there was no real like Sonja swith
the dark and the no music I just like I
can't believe that like these are the
most fabulous women in New York it was
honestly making me depressed no I agree
with that and I'm not and not because
I'm gonna compare fashion show at a
fashion show but like when they were
sitting at the table at that restaurant
I don't even know and they're just like
all screaming about nonsense and this is
just like a normal lunch and Dorinda
like okay tensley saying something
stupid but Dorinda is putting a knife in
her ear like what is going on at the sea
both these women who's just like
deranged no it was depressing and to me
it got to a level of real depression
when Tinsley was walking down the aisle
of that Fashion Show in sneakers and a
crown and her mom was literally sobbing
that she's back to being the socialite
that she used to be when like I'm so
sorry like you are not walking for a
designer I've never heard of looking
like Jojo Cielo yes yes No that outfit
was such a tragedy those sneakers like
and even though it's the designers call
what she wears like any designer that's
gonna put her in a Betsey Johnson dress
and sneakers like she's going to her
Scott Disick's Bar Mitzvah it's just
gonna be a no like it was it was
depressing and looking at those
flashback photos and like I
always want to be the type of person
when you look back on old photos of me
or like cringe because I'm so much
better now you know and like looking and
like looking back on photos in her prime
and now just like looking like Jojo Siva
um it was deeply upsetting and also you
know what was in interesting
juxtaposition an interesting
juxtaposition was the way that they
showed Nikki Hilton and Nikki Hilton was
like like she's probably the same age as
Tinsley and had a very similar like teen
and 20s and you know socialite life and
just like looking at her sitting there
with a ribbon in her hair just like
being everything of the sort of Pamela
Roland versus where Tinsley's now um it
was sad yeah that's it an amazing
parallel also Ramona being a beast
backstage like with Pamela rollin like
kicking back rod the photo like usually
that stuff that I loved but something
about this episode was just not funny to
me like I was just so disappointed like
I couldn't believe its maybe it's just
because I'm like living for this season
of Beverly Hills and like everything
they do is just [ __ ] glamorous like
the dress everything the houses it's
just like everything was making me
depressed like the John Makdessi and
stuff all of their apartments like it's
just it I don't feel like it's a
reflection of New York City's most
fabulous women no but maybe it's just
cuz New York City is not that fabulous
anymore also I feel like the biggest
difference is like there's like look at
Sutton's track she's obviously like very
wealthy very high society you know she's
looking down on everyone yet she chose
to be a real housewife of Beverly Hills
because there is some clout attached to
it um even when she had that weird
dinner with Teddy and Lisa Rinna and
Teddy's explaining like before I started
like before I started hanging out with
these women meaning before I came on the
show like I had a couple hundred
whatever clients and now I'm doing this
whole retreat and everything and I think
Sutton really came on the show because
she wants to make a name for herself and
she wants her clothing stores to succeed
and there's a level of prominence that
comes with being a real housewife of
Beverly Hills but then you go to New
York and it's like they went to a party
with the Suttons tracts of New York and
the way they behaved like no no it was
so disappointing maybe I was just in a
bad mood but like everything about the
episode was making me sad
like and there was a time when like
their antics of like being drunk and
silly like was funny and entertaining
and I just really feel and part of me
it's now kind of understanding why Duran
has been such a [ __ ] to Tinsley because
it's like Dorinda takes herself really
seriously and she thinks that she's like
some you know woman of the night she's
not but like she thinks of herself as
like really kind of prominent and it's
just like seeing Tinsley run around and
like living this delusion I kind of
understand it yeah I don't even know who
to blame cuz I don't even know who's
like helping the group average and who's
bringing it down
you know yeah I think that to me the
most harmless of of them all um is
shockingly like blue and she just like
doesn't even talk she just sits there
and she's boring now and she takes
herself really seriously and when they
go to parties like she always is like
thinks she's so highbrow she's the
countess and she yeah she's fine she's
neutral but like honestly during that's
fine too in certain situations like when
she decides she wants to be fine but
then I'm she's flying off the handle at
other times so I think that Sonja Ramona
and Dorinda are really like the three
culprits and then Tinsley and Lea are
just different like it's they're not I
like the Tinsley Fashion Show thing was
was utterly depressing but generally
speaking like I think when Tinsley shows
up to a party like she carries herself
fine yeah she's not like a public
embarrassment but some of the other one
in truly are it just must be this weird
thing where they're really like the
biggest celebrities in New York you know
if you're throwing a party you want
these women there cuz they're gonna
bring page six and news stories and what
was Ramona doing at the tables and that
becomes like a whole story and a
storyline on TV but when it comes to the
way New York City works I guess I don't
really know cuz I don't know what goes
on in the city I don't leave my house
like I don't know about Society in the
city so I don't know how they're
regarded I just know it's not the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills did you feel
like Sonja was being passive-aggressive
in giving um Lea that gray sweat suit
ultimately no I think it was what
Tinsley said like Sonja is not cool
enough to be passive-aggressive but I do
think that Sonja was
you're so casual you don't dress fancy
here's my casual outfit but she just
happened to send her a really ugly crazy
outfit but she liked her point was
you're so casual which was a little
sassy and even in her interview Sonia
was like I didn't know she would most my
dresses are fancy as if Lee is incapable
of being fancy yeah no I didn't think it
was like this strategically planned out
thing I honestly don't think Sonja's
capable of like plotting something like
that I think she genuinely like probably
in a rude condescending way sees Lee as
like this rat from downtown so she like
through her sweat suit so it wasn't like
the nicest thing but I didn't think it
was like this you know um
planned out thing and I think to someone
like you know a younger more downtown
person like there's a difference between
um like a sweat suit that she could have
worn to a fashion show that Leah would
have liked versus like a grout fit that
you're gonna wear to sleep like the hem
of those pants the drawstring like the
material like those were pajamas and and
I think for Sonja who's like lives you
know in a townhouse it's like your sweat
suit your track suit is pajamas to me so
here's some pajamas like she doesn't see
the difference between what we see is
like you know Yeezy cool but that
someone else's pajamas so I don't think
she was being like I think her only
statement was like Oh Leah you're you're
so casual but not like I'm gonna make
you look ugly and I'm gonna make you
feel bad and you know I I don't think it
was it was so malicious but she wasn't
guessing then which is that you you
don't wear fancy girlie dresses like
like they're any of us it was a
statement mm-hmm but I think she handled
it she handled it perfectly by putting
it on walking around like being like
just so funny about it
that you cause mad at her yeah yeah no
you can't I was just like by the end of
the episode I was like this is
surprising me like can I turn it off
yeah you know I didn't have that feeling
while I was watching it but now that you
say it I do agree
like even them just like sitting at the
Pamela Roland Fashion Show they're just
like so messy and like get the [ __ ] out
like honestly I was embarrassed for
Nicky Hilton for having to be like a
part of that yeah they really are just
so messy and everywhere you go it's just
like a big mess
yeah yeah but that's it anything else we
want to discuss so far we let everyone
go for the weekend um just that camcos
has been moved to September 10 through
13 so some people who had tickets can no
longer attend therefore tickets are open
up so go to the link in our bio in our
Instagram to get tickets the password
for the for the page is French camper
it's gonna be the best weekend ever I'm
literally so excited I feel like by then
that's in four months like things will
be returning to some semblance of
normalcy and like we'll be able to party
our asses off and I legit can't wait I
think it's gonna be the block party it's
gonna be like that that big party like
you know will be slowly making our way
starting on May 15th to you know getting
back to regular life and then on
September 10th like that block party
shirt soft it's out for the boys like
it's happening it's happening you guys
so make sure to head over to the link in
our bio on our Instagram channel um
Instagram account if you are looking for
more content all of our tienen shows
release new episodes to speak Olivia
released an episode with Amanda Stanton
Lauren Elizabeth Margot Joseph's has two
episodes this week Rabin and Alexis
there's tons of there's a new episode
snatchler so make sure you're following
tost news network on instagram and if
that's not enough for you head over our
patreon channel patreon.com slash one
each host for $8 a month you can get 5
extra premium video and audio episodes
from the morning toast we love you guys
so much thank you so much listening to
the morning toast will we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up if
you're watching us as a podcast
listening chances progress we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
we found Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio I already cashbox
all the places whoever you listen to
podcast fine that's the more you tell
asleep if I started be about a beautiful
setting a smart we are we love you guys
will be up a great weekend stay home bye